he was just a very giving person no
reason to take anything from Tommy or
try to take anything from him because he
would give it to you - my future
president my name is marcin Lee and I am
the proud parent of Thomas Lee on August
13 2008 my son Tommy was shot and killed
he was only 20 years old tommy was with
friends the night he died they had gone
to a community store on 140 seventh
Street in Loomis and Harvey Illinois
when my son exited the store he noticed
a man was standing near his car Tommy
asked if he could be of assistance
the man said he was waiting on his ride
and walked away when Tommy and his
friends got into the car
the man doubled back and pulled a gun on
them after Tommy's murder
I will ball up on a night and wish for
my own death it has been 8 years and my
son's case is still unsolved as the
parents of an african-american male who
was killed with the gun I am often asked
was he in a gang
the question is insulting to his father
his sister and to me what should be
asked is why are guns so readily
available the night time he died he
fought for his life in the lives of his
friends today I fight for the lives of
those who have yet to be affected by the
gun epidemic I work with groups to keep
guns out of the hands of dangerous
people and our next president should do
the same
we need universal background checks we
need to close the loopholes that allow
purchases on the Internet gun shows in
private events we need to keep more
mothers from losing their sons like I
lost mine
sincerely Marcia Lee Tommy's mom